yeah hello welcome to this video yeah
this is a new video on an opening yeah
it's not a very popular opening but an
opening that does pop up from time to
time and for the white players often
something that you're pretty much
surprised about because it's not played
often it's very aggressive I'm talking
about the Albin counter gambit yeah that
opening doesn't have a very sound
reputation and with some yeah with some
justification it's not particularly
great for black but if you don't know
what you do against it then it can be a
pretty decent practical weapon for the
black player that means if you are wide
then you play the Queens gambit you
better have something prepared against
it what I'm going to do in this video is
to show two ways for white to play
against the Albans there is one way and
this is the main line nowadays that is
pretty convincing I think in showing
that white should have an advantage
against this opening however we cannot
expect to win outright yeah it is not
that bad it's not like the Latvian
gambit for example which is pretty much
losing yea if white knows what what is
doing as I showed in an earlier video
against the Albans we can expect an
advantage but not to win straight away
there's actually a second option that
I'm also going to show at the end of the
video then it's somewhat related to the
line that I'm presenting you okay D
takes e5 white takes the pawn of course
and black pushes d4 that's the idea of
the Albans with that porn advancing
white is hindered here with this
development so that pawn on d4 is
obstructing White's position on the
other hand the pawn on e5 is also
obstructing blacks position so Knight f6
for example is impossible um yeah it
never struck me as being very logical
this opening but let's see what to do
about it
neither of three that's very natural we
that pawn on d4 and like is covering it
with 96 and here white has a big choice
many moves have been tried over over the
years for a very long time g3 was the
main line but nowadays this has has
changed and basically all books nowadays
recommend the move a 3 a 3 why such a
slow looking move on this side of the
board it has a very direct idea that
pawn on d4 is somewhat exposed if white
gets to play d4 and we should be - black
is almost unable to keep the pawn will
be very difficult for him to withstand
that pressure of three pieces attacking
at Queen Bishop and noid so this is
something that black has to take into
account now I cannot just ignore all
that idea also it just contains control
over the B 4 square which sometimes is
just annoying that there's a check for
example there is this famous idea you 3
bishop - check we should teach you and
takes takes check yeah and at the end of
all this is not the last cut wrap that
is even worse but here black also has an
excellent position so a3 is a good
multi-purpose move let's have a look at
this move a3
what is black supposed to do yeah here
he has an overwhelming main line then
main line is Knight g27 the idea is that
black is going to go ninety six and
trying to capture that e5 pawn we will
look at this later it's the main line
but first let's check what else black
has tried he has tried quite a couple of
moves and yeah we can pretty much say it
with some confidence that none of them
are really really any good
there's a five just looking to stop the
before the disadvantage of this is of
course that with a five being played
Black has a hard time to cast along
which is quite often the idea in the
Alvin's 9pg to now is good intending
night be three trying to pick up that
pawn anyway and well this is very
serious yeah
if black plays like 84 to prevent that
we will go before and takes takes and
this is falling and then it's two pawns
yeah I mean that's really something to
to take into account for black what did
you usually try Bishop g4 and now Clyde
is just going to play h3 attacking that
Bishop yeah black now can give up the
bishop pair on a3 or play Bishop h5
after Bishop h5 a very good movie screen
a form using that pin now that the pin
cannot be broken with any Bishop d7
why does some yeah wine is a lot better
here sometimes we can even go g4 with a
with a tempo another knowing move the
screen b3 and it's also very
inconvenient to meet you want to play
rook b8 e in this position hmm yeah as I
said there are many many good options
that can also take off course and
something like this but this has given
white the bishop pair now and in this
kind of position it is in fact very
useful that we have controlled the
square so in some cases we can just play
like a Bishop f4 and g3 III while it's
really just a partner like has no
compensation for that whatsoever so a5
is not really doing a good job like also
try to move f6 just getting rid of that
you fire porn however after the capture
Knight f6 and III it's really not clear
what blacks big compensation is note
that the
and he cannot support that on YouTube
before this is really repeating theme
throughout those nights we should before
we just play we should be too and this
is just just a pawn really black has no
particular compensation
note that if black is trying for some
kind of non canceling but quite sure
that even manager CSD for us hanging but
yeah on in general that a three move
also capacitors before b5 idea if he
cancels long so in three proves to be
quite a good quite a good move in many
scenarios if black the was Bishop e6
trying to cancel long quickly we go
night needy to covering c4 man g7 and
now Knight b3 before it's also I'm
pretty decent but we can look at that
point immediately Bishop him 90/60 for
so one important thing has happened
we've gotten rid of that obstructing
porn it's really a huge progress and
something like 94
Queenie for again where it's Plex
compensation for the porn it's pretty
much pretty much non-existent you know I
mean but it's not like you're winning
then white is not having also he doesn't
have a big attack against the king or
anything yeah it's not be losing but why
this right is a pawn up it's a double
porn but it's it's really nice position
to have so this should be six also
doesn't help
and then this Bishop g4 that looks maybe
that's more in may be the most active
looking move um but also not really
helping a lot we go Knight bTW to and
now black can try various things the
thing is how can you get to Castle long
I mean this is really a goal here if
Queen d7 is plate we're going before and
really asking back do you want to cancel
if this happens we have something like
Age 3 again b5 Queen a form yeah it's
rather white who's attacking here this
is the important thing
like really doesn't have any sort of
attack it's rather blacks King was in
more danger
we are pretty ok on only one and quite
often white will still play the G porn
and fee Aikido later
it's just a very very good position
sometimes black players try Queen d7 to
have a look at the e5 pawn this is
somewhat better than Queen d7 but again
after age three we should bench five
yeah if this happens black has some
problem of playing a good move now I
mean you want to cast along with after
Bishop g5 f6 it takes F G Bishop f4 it's
really questionable if black has enough
compensation yeah he's got relatively
good development but I'm going g3 should
be too
and this is still happening so it
doesn't really look very convincing and
Bishop g5 is not the only move you can
also play Bishop f4 that's also pretty
pretty decent Bishop h5 is the more
popular move in relative terms that
position is already quite rare Queen f1
getting ready to be active against the
long castle yeah long castles and now
before yeah it's we really counter
checking not just sitting there with the
pawn and hope for the best
umm yeah what what about this position
how can black continue if he takes only
5 we're going to check here note that we
cannot easily take here as d3 is pretty
awkward
check on the aid is not helping at all
so something else
what should white play yeah white has
good continuations here and we should be
towards one of them g4s the other one
who should be too as a bit simpler
getting this this pin setup and now
let's say King b8g for Bishop c6 Bishop
d2 yeah and it's rather white was having
an attack let's see how that line might
continue yeah and once attackers getting
getting overwhelming here really key for
us also under heavy fire um it is just
not any good this Bishop you fall on
castles idea it's important that white
is serve counter-attacking we're not
just sitting on the pawn so those are
the somewhat rare alternatives to now g7
now g7s by Father the best move and this
gives black at least a playable position
it's not particularly great but we will
see it's a playable position before and
that was the idea and now Knight to g6
you should be too and instead of matchy
six black sometimes has tried Bishop g4
by the way it's somewhat similar to an
earlier but now Knight f5 yeah sometimes
it has been tried but after green d3
sometimes intending queenie for white is
pretty substantially better you should
page 6 and therefore and that's really
bad so much better it's 96 this should
be true yeah and now black has a choice
he can play the move a5 insert that a5
b5 and then take only 5 I can't play the
move Knight
67 if black just takes the pawn let's
start with that are we going to capture
and then play the movie three that's an
important point
using that pin yeah
that should like to now the the only
really playable option is Bishop e6 and
now White's antiques on default let's
see for Quincy - we would see something
very similar in the in the main line
with a5 inserted this is just a somewhat
worse version of that because here the
Queen side structures somewhat more
favorable for white and Bishop e7
castles and now we see the problems with
this setup like him not castle now as h7
is under fire White has an additional an
extra center Claudia with the e pawn and
here some pressure like c7 9 is somewhat
misplaced 26 it's not yeah something
that I can expect to to win quickly but
what is much better
we should have 6 it's what they try here
and after the capture 93 White's
position is is just very nice for
example c6
you know and what enjoys a pretty
substantial advantage will probably win
a pawn here the C pawn is very likely to
fall it's a lot of work but yeah it's a
it's a great opening result so if we go
back the immediate night capture is not
helping like so they go a5 is this
somewhat better because now I'm to be
595 we reached pretty much the same
thing but now with a 5 and B 5 inserted
the pressure is a little bit reduced on
black still white is a bit better
we should be six-fifty
form and c4 in Quincy 296 this move has
been recommended some times but after 93
Queen g5 white is better in more than
one way the most convincing seems to be
Bishop c4 after which yeah this is Jack
just good for white walk we G to adhere
there's a funny line we should be six
tweenage one shot yeah and now 95 and
white is winning in the attack I know it
looks it looks a bit crazy but it does
wind yeah Queen a 337 check and the
threats are just just too too much yeah
something like this check yeah now
there's a big threat of queenie for so
let's say i don't know what black should
do like h6 just one move to show here
here james mate quite quite a funny line
but this is something that can it's
difficult to play this if you don't know
it yeah especially in an in a rapid or
blitz game but if you know that this
leads to winning attack you can go for
such things
yeah 25 it's not really doing the job
the best is indeed would like to just
just go back and now Bishop d3
we know this idea already and here Queen
g5 is the most most testing idea yeah
what should Y do now probably f4
covering this with the Queen and black
now goes to d5 or checks on h4 check
like this and this now just developing
yeah we can already see that right has
to be somewhat better here with this
better central control
nicely placed pieces on d4 and d3 but of
course this is not over yet Ian white is
better but it's not it's not like you're
you're winning quickly this is
especially true in comparison to some
other really bad gambits if you look at
blacks King position of blacks King
position is quite okay he has made the
strategic concessions in the center but
it's not like he's giving up it's not
materially down it has a blutbad King or
anything so you cannot just like to
chalk up your point if you if you see
the Albans played against you but you
can expect to have a good game black kit
also tried to smooth and ninety-three
3b3 after which white um yeah and the
trade is not bad for white but it seems
to be better even to keep the Queen on
the board with Queen f2 this is due to
an interesting line after Knight f5
white oops
white can take and go e4 this is pretty
strong one idea is that now after
castles long white can cancel short and
now after Queen c4 White has the very
strong move 495 yeah what is the point
of this it's a neat little tactic and
black grabs this pawn Jack yes this
Czech walking some black has to take and
after you see one why this meaning in
the Queen so this is not forced of
course yeah don't think don't tell me in
the comments
you said the albuns leads to force to it
of the Queen that's not true but I'm
just showing someone some ideas why this
in particular that Queen F to move is
good because it is only good because
this is precisely working yeah we have
to note that if white grabs here Bishop
c5 is going to kill white right away
again white is totally overloaded here
but should be for Queen is on that yeah
let's say I couldn't be won Jack Jack
check and what this is totally losing so
it's a pretty pretty narrow path here
too to an advantage so this is a good
line against the Albin's why am I saying
I present two lines isn't that enough it
it actually is enough but while I'm
checking this I happen to stumble upon a
recent show that was broadcasted on the
eyes to see where International Master
John Watson was asked what do you think
is good against the Albans and of course
I expected him to recommend a three but
he didn't he recommended a different
move and I had a brief look at it and I
have to agree that it's also pretty good
in some and lots of case actually
diverges post 283 that moves that BT -
that's an interesting alternative then
it's not as well-known what is the point
well the night very often goes there
anyway because the pawn on d4 is that
yeah obstructing force you cannot go to
c3 what should like do now the main line
is again nigt 7 you know just as after a
3 and it's funny in many cases we will
actually transpose to the a3 line for
example if black plays Bishop g4 looking
very logical then white is playing a 3
and we get exactly the position that we
had looked at earlier after a3 Bishop g4
Knight bTW - it's just a transposition
just to remind you it was something like
this a3 Queenie 7 an h3 Bishop Age 5
before we had this and then Queen a for
this kind of this kind of game look
earlier in the video for more on that
so Bishop g4 transposes what else is
there um let me have a look at my notes
yeah not much actually because Knight b3
is pretty awkward yeah what what else is
there I mean okay that can always kind
of
and layer six and and drop this porn but
as we earlier checked this is not going
to be enough enough compensation yeah
even night BD to comes into
consideration yep looking at this this
pawn directive look that's it's never
enough compensation something like
Bishop China maybe Bishop T to Queenie 7
but one can take check and play this
where exactly is blacks compensation I
don't see it
so f6 is not going to do any good
something like Bishop e6 for example can
be answered with night b3 as well and
we're going to pick up that porn again
when we are already one point up if we
get deformed we can easily trade D
against C podium yeah so what what what
do they play they play Knight GE 7 the
idea is that no after Knight b3 like him
can go Knight f5 to protect that point
that looks pretty pretty logical but I
still think that white is better because
what has sympathy for just attacking
that night and now blacks options are
very very slim he has to take the portal
open so there's really no alternative to
that otherwise you just lose before I
mean if you play this for example and
white is just happily grabbing the next
pawn so it's not going to work so black
has to take yeah now we just saturate
Queens Knight eeks yeah that's better
than King takes you don't want to give
up castling rights yeah now we just take
this and well what kind of endgame is
that what is a pawn up in this position
admittedly it's a double upon but still
the e5 pawn is a pretty it some nuisance
on your fire White has much better
central control and I just think that
this is a pretty bad endgame for black
we also have to take into account
that this kind of position is not
exactly what the hell bins coming again
but players aiming for defending an
endgame upon down so this is also an
excellent opening result and you can
argue that this is maybe even even more
promising than the main line of the a3
variation so if you want something a
very very low-maintenance
I mean a3 is also not particularly
sophisticated but if you want something
simple against the elements you can do
Knight bTW to Nagi 7:9 p39 a Frankie for
needs to the endgame and everything else
that black can do is rather rather very
fishy with Bishop g4 or as yeah it's
something like f6 where he's a pawn down
for not enough compensation so liability
was also very very good weapon 83 years
as I said the mainline nowadays and is
suggested in basically any book in borås
of rooks books and and in last
Randolph's book and so on and I checked
all the recent books they all have a
three it's good it's certainly good but
92mm as John Watson says it's also
pretty good so we can play one of the
two moves both can be can be recommended
without any any particular problem okay
I hope you enjoyed this video and now
you have something good against the
albans of your ID for player thanks for
watching